Ridley the list of films that you've
made is so diverse there's period in
contemporary there's intimate and
extravagant there's earthbound and
otherworldly what would you say this
movie allowed you to delve into an
explorer in a way that maybe you hadn't
before I neither noticed that question
first of all with me my plan is that
there was absolutely no plan whatsoever
and so I go I'm a little bit like a
child in a toy shop and I develop a lot
of material but when something comes by
that there's this special I grab it like
a teddy bear and so I read and the job
for me is reading you can't let someone
else read for you so I read the script
which was so called had been on the
shelf for a year or two and I read the
script and loved the play it's all based
on the play gentleman on the end there
the hardest thing to do in what I do for
a living is right the writing is the
single hardest thing once you've got it
on paper making the film is very easy
from my point of view and therefore it's
how I cast all these wonderful people to
actually do their thing and show me
what's what David your screenplay has so
many moving parts you're shuttling back
and forth between all the different
parts of the story and yet you really
have to keep the momentum going the
whole time how did you manage to do that
were you constantly going back to the
script to make sure that everything was
kind of propelling itself forward yeah I
mean I think to a certain extent the
movies kind of a hybrid strange hybrid
of you know what we think of as a
conventional kind of kidnapping thriller
and what we might call the great man
kind of movie all US citizen kane and
each of those genres in and of itself we
feel like we've seen before but this was
the effect of sort of smashing them
together and seeing what came out of
that and that was really what it was was
really sort of shuttling back and forth
between the sort of the the need to sort
of propel the movie forward as a as a
thriller but also be more introspective
and look into the lives of the
characters and the minds of the
characters Michelle there's so much to
balance as Gail she's going through this
traumatic experience
she's in a family situation that's very
complex and she's fighting back
what were the traits that you were
really focusing on and wanting to put
forward as you were playing her well one
of the things that I thought was so
interesting about is that what you're
really seeing is a woman operating in a
man's world and what it's like to have
those confines and how you try and work
within them to get the best result and
what I saw was a woman who kept coming
up against the walls of her own sex and
their sexism and as far as you know this
script is a our script was a perfect map
and the map told me you know she was
conceived as a woman and this is
entirely true the Italian press vilified
her because she didn't give them what
they wanted which was drama soap opera
confessional they wanted something that
they could sell and she refused to give
them something that they could sell she
kept her wits she kept her integrity and
she got her son back by refusing to fall
apart and mostly when we see her is in
conjunction is in relationship to other
people you know there aren't really a
ton of private moments for Gale so we
see her as someone who is actively
trying to keep things together and
that's really you know it was in the
script it was in what really happened
and the challenge then is to is to
contain all of that feeling all of that
emotion and and keep it together for
that long of a period of time Ridley
when the decision was made by the way a
month ago to reshoot twenty-two scenes
of this film and the movies done and
look how great it is
when you think about all of your
department heads and cast and crew who
had to drop everything and do this whose
life was made the most difficult by this
decision
I would imagine your location scout
would be up there our location manager
not Scout manager who else had to do the
most kind of Herculean work to get this
well the decision came pretty fast to do
it I met with dan Friedkin and Bradley
in an office from here I said we can't
let this fly and he said no so we're
gonna we did this prior to discussing
this with anybody including the studio
because this is Dan's film Dan's money
and I wanted to honor that process and I
could not let this fly and damage his
investment and I knew always I had
somehow I would get Christopher cuz
Kristin was always on the list he'll
probably say why the hell didn't you ask
me the [ __ ] boat that he was always on
the he was it was he and captain were
there together there's that's it
because when I read I'm seeing somebody
when I reading and going and that's how
I cast it with a very good customer so
anyway once the decision was made that
was made in a room a private he said
we're going to go for it right so the
person I will then call up with his my
line producer was more than that he's
very good producer Mark Hofmann was
Irish said right here's the lay of the
land
what now how do we find out so within I
would say 13 hours we knew what to do we
were going I had to go and see I had to
have make sure you're available make
sure you're available had it gone make
sure that he wants to do it and now I've
got a pop downstairs to see Mark
Wahlberg to say come on do it get your
awesome do it so that's what it was
so it's pure organization and once you
hit the ground running we all knew what
know what to do
it's about consummate professionalism
for everybody Charlie the character you
play as someone who a lot of people
would have a hard time relating to just
because of all the privilege that he
comes from but what was your way into to
him and feeling like you understood him
and related to him
well I think there's there is a lot on
the surface that I mean not a lot but
but certainly some things on the surface
level that I could connect to especially
you know this is a 16 year old kid who
was with all these adults at all times
and some of them were like Jagger and
Andy Warhol and and not that I've been
in those rooms but but there was
certainly that aspect you know I started
acting when I was 12 and I've been
surrounded by adults and some pretty
talented ones like these much of my life
and I think that there was certainly
that way and but I also think for this
character so much of what I think his
struggle is is being so isolated for so
long and and I think you know I think
that's definitely not being kidnapped
for five months but I think a lot of
people can probably connect to that
feeling at one point in their life
especially young people I certainly
could so I think that that was another
that I certainly connected with
Christopher talked about all the
different colors that you get to play in
mr. Getty colors that the man himself
might not have necessarily had we were
talking about and David I think you know
the other words that you crafted are so
fascinating was there one character who
you particularly relished fleshing out
with the dialogue I think Getty was a
very enjoyable character to write
because there's obviously a really kind
of strange psychology to the man you
know in terms of the cotton turn of
conflict within this guy he wants his
grandson back but he doesn't want to
spend any money to do it and so there's
this constant back-and-forth as these
things are playing out but he's also
smart you know he actually there's a
fierce intelligence there at work at the
same time and that's really interesting
is the guy who you actually have has
he's not shallow right in the sense it's
like he's got insight into money and
what it does to people he just doesn't
have insight into what it does to him
you know and that made him a really
interesting interesting character to
write but I think all of them were and
in their own way and Christopher what
was it like for you to read them in this
stuff the dichotomy between how he deals
with his money as far as not wanting to
use it towards the ransom but then we
see him you know buying these paintings
I mean it's just jaw-dropping
what was it like for you to read all
that and a mad
that all this was going on in this man's
head yes I agree I had all these offered
to me so nicely by the writer and I I
think my favorite scene in there was the
one in which he talks about how he likes
things better than people and sometimes
I agree with and that that gave me a
clue to try try instinctively to make
him a little more human than perhaps he
was sort of and I think that's important
because he can be doubly sort of evil
and tense if if you try to make him warm
like if Yago the worst villain of all
time if you play him with enormous
sort of charm he is more dangerous than
ever
I think great wealth can create the void
and the moat around the person who has
the money because I think it they become
withdrawn they will get we get withdrawn
for various reasons people who are
friends are no longer your friends envy
kicks into it envy is a very evil thing
and so the the person who is the target
of all this wealth has to withdraw and
therefore he's on his own so to a
certain extent I felt a little bit of
empathy it's felt kind of sorry for poor
Getty I think that's weak I learned the
interesting phrase in talking to you all
this morning which is the concept of
rehearsing on film and this was a way
that Ridley likes to work that Michelle
you described and it sounds very sneaky
I kind of but it but it seemed to work
can you explain shape did or any shape
did you get used to this idea of him
saying let's just rehearse it on film
and then saying oh that's the take um
that was great that's what I wanted look
I just loved it it made me wake up each
morning with a racing heart because I
thought oh boy you really have to come
out like all guns blazing there's no
warming up there's no getting
comfortable there's just your first
instinct the thing that comes off
top of your head before you really know
what could happen out there before
you've really worked out what the
problems are gonna be in terms of
blocking or dialog or interaction with
another actor before you work out what
the problems are and then solve them so
then it becomes a little bit safe we
would just launch right into it and it
became my absolute favorite thing and
now I'm just uh turley spoiled on it
because you're capturing something
that's really alive it's the first time
that you've done it you don't know
exactly where you're going you don't
know what's gonna happen but you're well
prepared and you're well cared for and
you just jump off the cliff and you do
it and and I it was exhilarating
ladies and gentleman thank you so much
for sticking around